[Musique]
c'est un homme discret plus à l'aise
avec les chiffres qu'avec les caméras il
fait partie de ceux qui révolutionne les
investissements de la caisse de dépôt et
placement du québec
notre objectif réaliser le meilleur
projet au meilleur trou le plus récent
le réseau express metropolit a le rer le
plus grand projet de transport collectif
au québec depuis 50 ans lui vaut même
les félicitations du premier ministre du
québec maquis le québec a beaucoup de
chance de vous avoir
né à bamako en 1968 macky tall grandi au
mali et dans les caraïbes à l'âge de 17
ans il déménage à montréal pour
poursuivre ses études universitaires
j'avais l'option bénessois étudié à
polytechnique ou à l'école des hautes
études commerciales hec voilà et puis
finalement assez mon grand frère qui a
fait la décision de dire qu'il prouvait
que hec et peut-être un peu plus cool et
donc j'ai fait des études de donc en
commercial en finance
mais de façon intéressante même si j'ai
une formation financière
toute ma carrière m'a amené à travailler
avec des ingénieurs avec le génie
lundi matin macky tall réuni son équipe
il faut faire le point sur les
investissements de la caisse dans les
quatre coins du monde
on fonctionne sur plusieurs fuseaux
horaires il est 7 heures à montréal 13
heures à paris
21h à new delhi 22 heures à brisbane en
australie
peu importe l'heure le suivi se fait de
près après tout il s'agit du fonds de
pension des québécois le portefeuille
infrastructures représente plus de 16
milliards de dollars
le secteur des infrastructures c'est
quelque chose qui est très concret qui
nous entoure lorsque vous vous déplacez
sur l'autoroute c'est une infrastructure
autoroutière l'eau que nous buvons ce
sont des infrastructures l'eau des
aqueducs
pour macky tall il n'y a aucun doute
l'avenir est dans la mobilité etc selon
lui investir dans les infrastructures
s'est aussi amélioré la vie de millions
de personnes dans le monde
l'avenir dans la mobilité est un avenir
beaucoup plus fluide beaucoup plus
efficace la caisse fait partie des dix
plus grands investisseurs en
infrastructures dans le monde
nous avons eu deux bambins également et
c'est ce qui compte dans son bureau il
ya ce qu'ils surnomment les pierres
tombales
c'est à dire les transactions réussies
de la caisse à travers lui c'est celui
que nous avions compléter
l'investissement d'un bea dans
l'aéroport heathrow de londres
d'eurostar le train à haute vitesse qui
relient londres paris il espère ajouter
le raismes à son palmarès la caisse
finances et gère la construction de ce
train électrique de 67 km le quatrième
plus gros réseau de train automatisé
dans le monde
le renne c'est un système qui va être à
la fine pointe de la technologie un
système de train léger automatique
quasiment un deuxième métro pour
montréal mais pour que ça marche il faut
expliquer écouter consulter rassembler
mais surtout convaincre si le projet
suscite la controverse
mais quitte à la proche d'une manière
différente ses plus ardents détracteurs
comme
environnementalistes et agriculteurs
j'ai rarement vu un promoteur comme la
caisse de dépôt ou si proactif pour
faire des modifications qui ont fait
plus d'une modification vingtaine de
modifications depuis l'annoncé initiale
du projet il ya deux ans qu'on a eu une
entente avec la caisse de dépôt la
communauté métropolitaine de montréal
pour la création d'une fiducie foncière
qui va permettre de protéger les terres
près de la gare ceux de l'étalement
urbain
il faudra voir maintenant si leur m
aidera la caisse remplir sa mission
première c'est de générer du rendement
des rendements stables à long terme mais
c'est rarement ils servent en fait à
vraiment assurer une sécurité financière
à des millions de québécois mais je vis
au québec
mon épouse est québécoise mes enfants
sont québécois donc c'est une façon
vraiment de prendre tribus et au québec
après avoir géré le portefeuille
infrastructures
macky tall vient d'être promu chef des
investissements de la caisse qui vise
haut pour sa terre d'adoption
avec cette même ambition d'être la
meilleure équipe dans le doute
[Musique]